look
oh
get in take you for a ride
as soon as i saw you that time and
thought to myself
those are some balls on that one and i
definitely need someone with a pair for
this job
never mind the testicles tell them to
keep those hands at ten and two
always wound up in a ditch whenever
kerry drove
so what good will my balls do us today
three some people in this town
they've gone completely whacked you
you're gonna help me set things right in
this [ __ ]
how's that exactly there's this little
girl group
us cracks right three birds from japan
laser pop scop big over in asia
i mean now they signed some
deal for an nus tour wanna promote it
with a cover of my song
can you believe that not about to let
them play me like that
right so what's the plan
the truck with the us cracks kid will be
coming this way
we do it old style like last century
we blow the [ __ ] up no gear
those [ __ ] will have to cancel
concerts kerry
solving his own problems he used to just
send in an army of lawyers
they made it all disappear while he
tanned his bare ass by the pool
must be some [ __ ] indeed
be there in a second
[Music]
[Music]
here we are
truck grab what's in there
you got it you know they killed
iv coma right here in this very spot
dj cloaked av followed her limo
almost nothing left of her afterwards or
a lemma
turned out later she wasn't a target
some biotechnica suit
busy eating her out when the bullets
started flying
found the bodies just like that
lay it out here
right high quick
so
what now now we wait
automated modules hollow spikes for
better control of the vehicle
standard issue police take nate's too
where'd you get him same place you get
designer drugs
the latest still patent pending audio
vox and fresh jabaris
black market ah fans
there she is right on the dots
i take the driver you get his side shoe
we want him out of the truck
what are you doing the hell was that out
of the truck
on the ground hands like and see him
get out ground now
hey man listen on the ground i said
man lose the iron let's talk it out not
a word
all be over soon ah [ __ ] now
access guard grab it quit squirming in
the back and no gonk moves
what's inside
your lucky day care crates and crates of
nothing but gear
got your mixers speakers drums cables by
the mile
hell yeah we got a hit right gents
now run along and don't look back
i said delta the [ __ ] off
now for the grand finale want this set
to be a smoldering puddle of chrome and
plastic when we're done
you're the boss lighter up
[ __ ] yeah good working with you
[ __ ] me carrie meaning it's just a truck
of toys for some plastic japanese dolls
might as well blow up a cotton candy
stand
but still a big step forward
i hardly recognize the bastard it's
burning real nice
i'll grant you that the thing is
what's it actually get you those little
[ __ ] think they can make it big on my
song they got another thing coming
you even know what i had to sacrifice to
get where i
am the price i paid for success
and those 10 annie [ __ ] want to clep
my tune
and expect me to just let them [ __ ]
big ignorant hacks
yeah success always a sore spot who
cares
see nothing's changed
that's how you do biz in night city
respect care
you get me finally thanks
cops it's delta you try
get him off our ass
[Music]
oh [ __ ] last time i ran for the cops
back in johnny actually
high out of our damn mind picks still
good catches
[Laughter]
these cogs don't stand a chance [ __ ]
pigs
a single eddie okay drop me off on
carnitas
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
carry uridine eats at a dump like this
best coffee in town right here the
thickest tar
and if they know you they give you
organic stuff
come on my treat
wow coffee with a rock star now why not
first time for everything
hey what's your trauma samurai started
out
we spent every enemy we had i'm going to
tell you about
training they let you bring two other
people with you
remember when they shut up hey rachel
arguing with you good morning
you started know this dump know that
smell
but how yep hello
well i'll be damned
ah almost nothing left over for food but
we still went across the street every
day
right to caliente stuffed our faces
down joe by the gallon johnny said we
were so hungry and high we would have
eaten the cardboard boxes out from under
the bums outside
of course he was wrong
the usual mr eurodyne um
double espresso jamaican blend nothing
else
no sugar you got it and for you
what he's having great be right back
with it
oh [ __ ] just coming down now
[ __ ] awesome last time i felt like
this was back in memphis
last tour less concert vibes from the
crowd
me on stage oh [ __ ]
just thought about those us cracks [ __ ]
again
you think we got him
i'll tell you this much if they don't
back out now give me a call
we'll convince them another way thanks
hope they're off my sonar now cause if
not
[ __ ] last thing i want is johnny to have
been right
all along
johnny's dead
so they say and you're alive
decide whose truth matters more to you
yours are someone else's
that a trick question only if you don't
have the nads to answer it honestly
better be going thanks for
you know don't mention it